hey guys how's it going welcome to our
second day here at Zion park we're about
to hike to Angel's landing is that right
angels landing yes angels landing oh so
we're going it's also raining so we were
going to do an original tour where you
have to like hike through the river but
there's this thing called flash Bloods
and it's a little bit dangerous so we
decided to not Ford the river and do a
hike I got a coffee completely necessary
and I have myself
well the lodge we need a
body
oh my goodness it's so pretty yet trial
facts
I mean she's five miles tell me i
strenuous here we go I gotta get my
quest bar I I had to give in we have
even started yet um I'm aware everywhere
that is an ant good thing of that oh oh
lapse time seven minutes we have a lot
of time left
Oh
guys I got some disappointing news for
you the entire hike is not in fact
sidewalk
you
we're about 40 minutes into our hike
almost to the halfway point this place
is absolutely beautiful if you guys ever
get a chance to come here honestly don't
think oh and also don't look with the
Ziggy Martin garrix
such as long this all walk up here
I hear everywhere
Thanks careless Beulah
don't look down you're currently
cruising up feed Walters Walters wiggle
can't believe how natural these bricks
look
Walter designed this he's really pleased
well guy
look at this edge look at this edge look
at that edge how far we have left half
not half a mile half mile
let me go all the way back down look at
this my eyes have seen some amazing
things
we had to take a little quest bar break
a little snack break a little water
break we're almost there
we're gonna do it we were contemplating
turn it back but I think we should do it
guys we should just go to the top
Barlow's down but I just can't help
thinking this is like you know a DLC a
far cry and I can just like forgetting
roll out with my little shoot man I'm
losing helicopters fantastic Jen Far Cry
DLC like the Far Cry DLC featuring Jenna
Justine maybe
so we officially just finished the hike
we made it up to angel's landing and I'm
gonna give you guys our total time here
four hours and six minutes let me stop
first total distance six point seven six
miles average heart rate 107 I am ready
I don't even wanna say it but I'm ready
for Starbucks this is oh so much fun we
we did it we accomplished our goal of
not dying how'd you do Jen we did I
can't wait to pee we're off destination
oh boy